thank you
[Music]
so let's talk about uh the poo poo let's
talk about poo poo we it's not a JK day
unless we have one video talking about
some [__] poo poo what about poopoo
actually you can talk about actual [__]
or Putin yeah no actual [__] actual poo
poo Okay an expert explains how often
you should be pooing on a date what's
the number well before we even get to
that where's everybody where's everybody
here I've read I [__] once a day times a
day I'll tell you what what I'm a [__]
expert Shakespeare because I've been
skinny I've been fat I've been in the
middle and I've tracked my calories so
when I'm eating like what my maintenance
calories are I usually [__] like once a
day and they're like pretty small and
then when I started what do you mean
when maintenance calories what is that
so like what my body needs to survive
okay so we gotta get the same okay
gotcha most people eat more than what
they need that's you so so you're once a
day it's this baby
so when I'm like going crazy when I'm
going crazy I'll [__] like two three
times a day wow and all of them are big
because I'm eating way too much food
that my body can't even process does
diarrhea count
um I don't get that that often okay
because you're not eating crazy
well I think my I have like iron guts
like I could probably drink milk and
drink vodka and it'll be like fine
interesting yeah but you pass out in
like three seconds I pass out but I
could like I could probably eat someone
else's throw up and I'll be fine
how do you get to these places uh the
voices
[Laughter]
[Applause]
everything he says is like like we like
we should all just be normal with it
like yeah yeah now you go yeah yeah
exactly yeah it's so funny it's like
we're with him so much that we're like
yeah this is a normal bar [__] and then
you're like dude this is not normal yeah
and you're like oh yeah you're right I
think that way too crazy
but no so go back to the eating people
set up thing so when I'm on a hardcore
cut I'm literally [__] [__]
acorns because your body's absorbing as
much nutrients [__] push so hard and
it's like
is that constipation when you say you're
on a hardcore cut in comparison to the
other ones does that mean you're eating
less than yeah so like let's say my
calories my maintenance calories let's
say it's like 2 000 or something right
if I'm on a hardcore cut I'm only eating
like 12 to 1500 then I'm not eating
enough food so like my body's absorbing
as much of it as possible so everything
that's coming out is a real biological
waste when I was in a biological waste
product when I was when I was a skinny
little [__]
um oh damn I weighed like 120 in high
school okay and I and I didn't eat that
in elementary school yeah I was I was
hella skinny I was like 100 I was like
130.
because you were a menace [__] adults
but but um I I probably [__] like once
every several days really yeah I
probably didn't need it you were eating
yeah but that was also when you were
part of that religion no
drugs
the religion of drugs yeah I'll be like
you know what I want to [__] get
really [__] up today so I'm not gonna
eat wait doesn't cocaine make you [__]
no it was ecstasy [__] like yeah XC
makes his [__] one time in the beginning
and it's glorious anyways carry on I
never [__] on ecstasy you never did no
everyone told me it's good but I never
really it's like a thing people do when
you [__] on ecstasy you want it to last
forever really you wish the poop could
just be like three feet long so it just
keeps coming up like your eyes are in
the back your head like oh
that's the actual thing people do on XC
and they like purposely well you don't
time it but when it happens you're like
I think I gotta go you're like happy
about it you're like happy about it what
is that character
wait so what well okay wait so what's
the normal
amount answer the question
two times twice is it like a morning and
a night yeah pretty much I'm once a day
at around soon
you'll see an empty chair from one of
the videos yeah
[Laughter]
that's just because he's doing karate in
the back
he's doing orbs in there so he's like I
gotta do a business call and he'll just
leave for like I pee a lot oh I pee a
lot and then
um yeah they just did you get distracted
in there yeah there might there might be
a time where I pee and then in the
middle I go you know what I haven't
checked my body out in a minute so I
[__] strip off my fry and I flex and
I go still got it
and we're just sitting here waiting for
him like all right
get out here by six o'clock
wait wait how many times like one or two
I'm once a day now but growing up I was
the same I was like once every two or
three days yeah damn mine's once again
is it like is it like clockwork for you
guys around like for me it's around like
10 11. yeah usually in the morning yeah
yeah it also yeah my eight in my ten
o'clock yeah mine's like clockwork plus
if you drink coffee like if I drink
coffee that day then it's for sure
that's the thing that [__] me up
because like I wake up in the morning
and then I'm like all right I need to
poop and I'll sit on the can but it's
not like ready because when you go from
like bed to the can you haven't like
really done some digestive work yeah and
then I'll get up and then I'll like do
stuff and drink some coffee and I'm like
[__] I gotta go again yeah oh you know
what I have to prove sometimes too is
like right after a meal and I'll start
walking Yeah Boy gotta poop oh yeah
immediately almost oh like you you can
do the immediate like right after you
eat my parents used to be like there's
something wrong with you I mean it would
like kind of scare me because like I
would we would eat dinner as a family
sometimes and then I'd be like I gotta
go poop I would announce it obviously
because that's what people do in
families and then my dad be like there's
something wrong with you you should not
be pooping right after you eat so your
food but that's normal a lot of
my dad doesn't know what the [__] he's
talking about
where's your md [__] right you
digested food that fast sometimes you
should probably still full of jetting is
it depending on what you eat though or
is it like like if you had like a just a
[__] I don't know like a piece of
toast something with a lot of fiber whoa
if I eat something with a lot of fiber
I'll I'll hold it a little bit longer
it'll take a while which isn't normal
right like okra you know what I'm saying
okra [__] you [__] with okra yeah I
mean fruits vegetables okra like yeah
because it's slimy I don't know is that
fiber or is that just slimy I do feel
like I need more fiber in my life
nowadays yeah it's really easy to go
through like a normal Mega yeah and
actually not get a lot of fiber well
that's that's like a it's like a big
thing like health-wise like you have to
try to make sure you get enough like
people like 90 of people don't get
enough don't get enough fiber you know
the most ancient like you know how they
talk about paleo [__] right most like
Hunter gathers and all the ancient [__]
what they find in their bellies and if
you look at like tribes today most of
their diet is fiber it's not protein
proteins [__] hard to catch so then
most of it is like they're digging up
Roots
I thought protein was kind of everywhere
though
not always man it's hard to hunt and
catch it oh you got it you got to be
skilled you gotta eat it right away too
because it couldn't refrigerate so they
didn't eat protein every single day but
like you could get Roots you could dig
up Roots you could find you know
whatever the staple is for that tribe
you know what's crazy the longest I went
without [__] was like four straight
days whoa because I was at because I was
at surf camp when I was in seventh grade
and the bathroom was so was so nasty the
bathroom's so nasty I was afraid to use
it so what did you do surfing [__] yeah
well I just I stopped eating the meals
at the camp and I would just eat like
kitkats to like what yeah for four
straight days that is the thing though
when I was a boy scout and I was camping
all the time too you would you would
hold your [__] yeah and you would not
want to [__] at the camp because it just
wasn't a [__] toilet like you're used
to all the time you have to poop outside
yeah so you would just be like I don't
want a [__] today finally got home like
from camp and I and I [__] it looked
like I made a [__] Oscar award wow
it's like perfect yeah
yeah what's average the latest findings
from one of these studies uh and uh from
a guy named Dr Tim Spector well sounds
like a villain's name no no right uh
another guy that killed somebody my [__]
this much he said that a pole a poll
revealed that 55 of people relieved
themselves once a day 32.4 go twice each
day and around 10 poop three times a day
uh and according to Dr Tim they're all
relatively correct in in a sense and
it's too inclusive I don't know yeah
it's too inclusive anything what about
people that don't [__] everything
anything from three times a day to three
times a week is considered normal that's
[__] everything then what the [__]
three times a week some participants
claim to be going five times a day and
uh that's bragging that's bragging and
some 10 inch dick too I bet yeah let's
get those [__] yeah
Mandingo over there with your five inch
dick yeah yeah I bet you think you're so
cool right you're a real hot shot huh I
bet he has a 3.0 GPA
2.8 GPA and he says that some people go
once a week so you know on the on the
extreme but everything's like so five
times three times no that's an extreme
sense whereas I know a skinny girl that
goes once a week once a week yeah is she
is she okay
that's wild she's a food vlogger three
times a day to three times a week and
then she lays an egg
she gives birth to a small baby damn
dude oh
I'd go crazy if it was just once a week
yeah you'd be like something's wrong I'd
feel clogged up yeah I'd be like yo I
gotta [__] you get a potty Squad a
potty squatty squatty squatty pie those
are lit those actually work oh yeah
those are pretty cool I don't know just
it lifts up your legs so that the the
way that your actual organs how do you
try to get [__] up
like a gynecologist yeah the toilet is
like this delicious
there's a Target you look like those
Olympic divers that are [__] yeah
[Laughter]
you see how I got there you see how I
got there but it's more like this you're
still sitting upright but it lift your
legs up this way yeah and that's not
making it too real now it's more natural
position right and so what that you have
to [__] you're sitting at an angle
Vortex for your [__] down to release
posted like a minor [__] intestines
or some [__] and then get your
sphincters all along I guess that's the
correct ancient way people chat yes
lubricant does it he does I'm sure he's
got a date yeah I'm sure he doesn't [__]
at all he goes I take a nice five pound
[__] every day
does he yeah that's what he said that's
what he says I don't know if that's true
that's [__] huge that's really big
that's throughout the day
he said just once a day that's what he
says with his five-inch dick
[Music]